on average a million streams is around
four thousand dollars USD on Spotify on
Spotify and we're averaging like 60
million streams a month right now things
are just pretty crazy and I don't think
most people know that there's that
potential because
in music you hear there's no money in
streaming but I'm like that's because
labels own 80 of your songs but if you
own your songs there's a ton of
money in streaming
[Music]
laughs
okay welcome first
um
so I don't know what the real intro of
this is gonna be but I I wanted to
introduce this to you guys uh Sam had
put this on the calendar like Hey we're
recording with Connor and uh Brianna and
I think he those you guys in person or
real life or whatever
and he kind of loosely said I was he
said something like oh I was like is
that the rapper kind of music person
and then what I was doing the prep for
this I was like oh it's these these
people oh my God I love I love your
stuff I am so excited for this uh as you
can probably tell because I'm screaming
but I'm so excited for this because I
think what you do is literally amazing I
think it is so smart and I think it is
so impressive what you've done
um you know we've had the chance to talk
to Mr beason's podcast and we've talked
to Hassan minhaj in the comedy World
we've talked to some Cody Co on the
YouTube side who you kind of look like I
think you know that
um but I do I gotta say I think you are
playing Tick Tock like a fiddle I think
you have figured out like the thing
every platform that comes out there's
like there's like the people that like
kind of come from the old world onto
that and just kind of try to do the same
thing but maybe shorter or faster or
video or whatever
um and then there's people who figure
out that medium for what it is and I
think you figured out how to do music on
Tick Tock like nobody else
um I don't know if you're a marketing
genius or if you fell into that but
either way it's working and therefore I
am so excited to have this conversation
because last night
you could tell I'm kind of tired because
I was binging your content and I was
just so inspired I was so inspired I
don't do anything in the music world I
bet 99 of the listeners don't do
anything in the music world but I was so
inspired just by what you were doing so
that's my intro of just uh Fanboy
because I can't believe how good you
guys are what you do that was the nicest
intro well thank you so much yeah no as
far as the marketing stuff goes that's
all Brianna um which is why it's so fun
to be able to do this conversation with
her
um because we we do everything together
uh but so so many of my ideas that have
gone viral are her ideas so let's give
people a little context and we could
either explain it or I do think it would
be better to literally just show it so
I'm gonna I love the show method so I
have a bunch that I liked
um dude you know how much I like this I
was last night so I'm doing this on my
laptop and I'm not logged into Tick Tock
and I kept hitting the like button and
like you know I was like trying to like
it and it's like create an account and I
almost created a second account just to
give you the like because I was so I
felt like you deserved it uh like oh
thank you even when you feel like
someone earned it that's how I felt I
love it play a video play one of the
videos yo yo yo what is he
oh yeah so he was telling me that if you
uh if you cut a carrot a certain way you
can play it like a flute he really
thinks it's gonna work apparently it's a
thing
just ignore him ready uh yeah do me a
favor pull up
[Music]
pull up that one session
yeah look they said that I couldn't do
it so I wouldn't do it did it W's only
you know I've been winning top of the
world the globe is spinning spinning if
you know you know I've been on it
okay let's get it got a little time on
my hands like a wrist watch I don't got
time for the brakes and the pit stop
breaks through the gridlock take it like
Chris right to the chance to win heavy
metals like Slipknot got to drive and I
got tunnel vision I just hit my stride
the way I run the business I've been
making paper like I'm done to Memphis
see the end game I got one division look
I don't ever bother with a Critic hit
him with a Chronicle already boom so you
create these these little like
um opening skits and you'd you don't hit
them like okay traditional way of doing
things somebody wants to be a musician
they're going to fire up
Tick Tock and they're gonna just play
their song maybe they play the song with
a music video already baked in and if me
if it's me and I'm just hearing the
opening of a song it's usually pretty
slow there's a little bit of a build up
um you know just like the just a little
bit of instrumental playing at the
beginning or they might say hey I'm Sean
this is my new track give it a listen
right kind of boring sort of begging for
attention whereas you have these little
opening skits that gets you curious of
what's gonna happen you're playing all
these characters like you know Eddie
Murphy in uh whatever that movie was
you're sitting here Tyler Perry and
you're playing all the characters and
then then you hit them with a track
that's actually like surprisingly good
for how simple the intro is I don't know
how how to explain it but this is how
you got famous for doing this stuff on
Tick Tock sure yeah no so I make music
um specifically in the kind of hip-hop
rap World a little bit of Pop sometimes
but yeah so with the whole goal with
these videos is to not make it seem like
you're selling someone especially on
Tick Tock the moment you feel like
someone's like hey check out my song
you're going to swipe away so you have
to provide entertainment first and we
have found the best way to do that is
through skits and it was really easy
because Connor's been acting since he
was six years old so it was the perfect
way to kind of merge those two worlds
and it it worked yeah I saw you were in
a bunch of like well good luck Chuck a
bunch of yeah a bunch of movies I
started acting when I was six in Toronto
where I grew up started with commercials
when I was 10 I did a movie called
Cinderella Man I played the son of
Russell Crowe in that film and that was
kind of the first huge project I was
ever a part of first time I went to LA
for the premiere signed with the US
agent and so from a kid I've just been
doing TV and film my whole life and then
when covet hit and production shut down
I was like what do we do I was working
at Alpha paw at the time the pet company
um I left that job and then I was like
okay Conor's really good at rapping he's
he's loved hip-hop for so many years why
don't we try marketing that and he
didn't want to because he thought Tick
Tock was kind of lame like it was in the
era where people just did those little
dances so yeah I took some YouTube
videos he had filmed turned them into
vertical pieces of content he's like I'm
a thespian I'm not going to be on Tick
Tock I'm an actor
films my biggest regret is not starting
sooner on like social media specifically
I'd always been anti that once he saw a
video go viral and then it translates to
streams the next day he's like okay
maybe we can do it I changed everything
yeah every every time yeah let's pause
for a sec yeah we got to say the
background here because people said
Alpha Paul so basically I I'm friends
with Ramon who then became me Sean Ramon
are all buddies Ramon is on episode two
or three or four Sean talks to him he
had a pet it's episode two he had a soap
opera company and then a pet company I
remember Ramon bought this pet business
that seemed outlandish at the time
turned into a successful business I went
to Vegas to hang out with them I think I
was there regardless and I just went to
hang out to the office Brianna was his
right-hand woman running marketing and
everything else at the company I go to
this brand new office set he has and
remote's like uh Connor is Brianna's
wife she he's actually just gonna help
us move he's uh trying to make it are
you trying to make it everyone told me
that you showed up like uh high on drugs
because you were afraid of flying so
you're like you're like dope I hated
flying and I took up I took too much
medicine and I got to I like I was still
figuring out the dosage and I got to the
office I was like I gotta go to sleep so
I was like all messed up I was like I'm
sorry guys I'm like intoxicated but I I
remember meeting when I was moving yeah
yeah he was moving boxes like you were
because you were an actor and you were
in between and you're just moving
and then like months later he Ramone was
like hey remember Brianna's wife her
husband she uh he's like trying to
actually become a rapper and he's
actually good and I'm like the guy
moving what really I I don't buy it I I
don't buy it and then you had like some
traditional rap music videos and I'm
like okay he actually is quite good then
uh Ramon was like hey uh Brianna's
actually left Alpha Paul and she and
she's gonna take over his and then
I start seeing a tick talks and I'm like
oh my God this guy's the best and then
you blew up and now it looks like you
have like eight million monthly lessons
on your Spotify he remote's telling me
that you guys are independent yeah so
you like own all the music and he's like
saying like dude they're numbers for
Revenue are outlandish you can say if
you want or not but like they're making
a really good living now Conor's going
on tour he's with Hoodie Allen he's in
Europe he's selling out shows in Europe
and now you're like legit famous he
looks like your top song spinning has
105 million downloads the other one is
74 million like you guys are killing it
and I knew you just as this nice guy who
was moving boxes and this was only I
think this was three years ago this
wasn't long enough
first time we met was at a comedy show
five years ago in 2018. do you remember
that it was like a Chris Delia show and
then yeah you came to the office I think
you and I were like butting heads that
day and then Ramon's like oh he's just
on drugs and I'm like okay that makes
sense yeah well Ramon told me yeah voice
message to me last night he's like yeah
same same game office but he was like
you know a little bit like doped up from
the the flight and he goes you know Sam
normally asks like pretty direct
questions like add drugs oh Sam was
getting behind everyone's laptops like
what are you doing what are you doing
and I'm like I don't remember that I
don't remember that I'm sorry you're
making my team nervous as hell and
Brianna you don't know this but uh I
also saw your work before we ever met
because you were behind a lot of the ads
so Alpha paw scaled like crazy so Ramon
bought this business that's a dog ramp
business initially so it was literally
like it was called sausage dogs that's
right wow which is also what they used
to call my dorm in college but but then
so well played so then um it's like
little dogs use the ramp to get up on
the bed or on the couch or down from the
couch I have four of them in my house
because I got a little dog and I also
know Ramon so he sent me four four free
ramps so there was uh so these rants are
great but I was like how do you sell
these like are people looking for these
he's like no most people don't realize
they want it so we gotta like make ads
that teach them that they want it and I
was just getting into Ecom I had I was
Ramon's the reason I started an econ
brand because I was sitting at his house
hearing the Shopify Ching cha ching on
this phone I was like dude I want that
noise in my life how do you do that so I
decided to start one and to help me he
goes he's like here um
I added you to my ads account which is
like basically like adding you as a
co-signer on a bank account basically
nobody gives their Facebook ad account
to somebody else but that's very
intimate Simone is that kind of guy that
kind of friend and so I'm in the ad
account and I'm looking at all your ads
that you created because you had all
these video ads that were working to
sell pee pads and ramps and all this
stuff and I was like damn I need
somebody who's good at creating ads and
I think was is it right that you were
just kind of like at that warehouse or
you would just like come up with the
concept yourself and figure out like
test them is that kind of where you got
this like quick video you and your
sister it was mainly myself and
Catherine do you remember Catherine um
Catherine and I ran the marketing and
then my little sister would help me but
basically we would just try and like
either
pull at someone's heart strings like we
would start a video with maybe an
injured dog and then instantly a person
that has an injured dog can relate to
that and they're like all like and then
we show the solution and then a cute
little dog we literally bought a
Chihuahua she's upstairs just to use
like for marketing ads and we would show
her trying to jump up on the couch and
instantly everyone that has a Chihuahua
is like oh my dog does the same thing
boom here's a solution and it just
freaking worked it was wild like I've I
couldn't believe it we went from an
office as big as a bathroom to like a 20
000 square foot Warehouse within a year
yeah I was I was doing a lot of moving
Connor was moving a lot Conor would help
film he would help edit the ads yeah it
was a family production and then all the
high performing ads we filmed in either
our living room or Chloe's living room
yeah in our house and then when I was
like okay I really want to do my own
thing we want to start a family I need
to leave this pet company it broke my
heart for Mom's my best friend but I had
to ultimately leave and I was trying to
start other companies I'm like what can
I start I started like a coffee brand a
like a Christian brand and then our
friend Cliff Weitzman he's the CEO of
speechify oh we know I believe you know
I love Cliff he says hello I was talking
to him this morning I said I was going
to be on him yeah Cliff was over for
dinner and I was just venting my
frustrations of product boredom and he's
like Bree stop like this is your product
he's like Kris Jenner the out of
him so the next day I stopped I had a
huge order an inventory of coffee and I
let it go to waste and I'm like we're
going all in on this and I pretty much
just use the same mindset I used to sell
the dog ramps to sell his music it's
like how can we hook someone in and how
can we tell a story around this song
because a lot of Music These Days is
just like a really cool beat and like
some generic lyrics right but I'm like
there's a lack of Storytelling and I
think that's what music online is
missing and we did it so and we're doing
it independently so so you can see it
because as I was doing my my binge I
can't even call it research I was just
enjoying myself going down I did the
Tour de France down your profile the
first video actually on your YouTube
channel is pretty dope I don't know Sam
have you seen the very first video that
they the first song that he posted is it
is that the one where you rap about how
you have a sweater yeah yeah yes yeah
yeah what is it called the s word or
what is it would you call it it's just s
just the letter s
um so you rap about how you used to have
a stutter and then yeah in the song
You're basically every like a bunch of
the words start with s and uh by the way
you sent me down a Watsky Rabbit Hole
two last night like we love huge huge
inspiration for that I've never heard of
him he's dope um
so anyways the that's the first song and
it's like okay this person clearly has
talent but also it's like I don't know
that's different yeah it's never been
easier to go on I don't know Froot Loops
and make a beat and and then and then
try to try to rap and like do 15 seconds
of a good rap like that's I guess never
been easier would you say like it's kind
of more competitive than ever to do that
part totally totally I mean there's what
60 000 songs uploaded everything could
be more I think the data is closer to
100 now but roughly I'd say does we save
60 000 songs uploaded every day yeah
they the the the ease of being able to
make music now especially in the hip-hop
space with with
um programs like Fruity Loops where you
can find samples yeah
um it's yeah a lot of people are making
music way more efficiently than ever you
can see like kind of the progression
like okay are you getting some views
you're putting out some good tracks but
like there was all I could almost draw a
line and be like then they figured out
how to create like hooks for these
videos yeah it was the presentation
everything was different after that is
that when you joined uh Brianna like is
that kind of when you Chris gendered the
out of them yeah that's when I
really stopped trying to do a million
things and focus just on him and the
biggest moment for us was creating a
series that's when we started the spin
the globe Series where he would spin a
globe and land on a country and collab
with an artist that took us from like
here to like yeah that took off like
crazy that that first video that we did
where we landed on Zambia and found the
Zambian artist that that video has 72
million views on Tick Tock and 72
million views on YouTube shorts so
explain that video yes yes so it was an
idea where I had this song with this
artist named Killa who's this
independent artist from Zambia when we
first worked with him he had less than a
thousand monthly listeners had 189
monthly listings and now he's over a
million because that song which is
incredible wow and it's like changed
changed his life
um but essentially we were like all
right how can we Market this and I was
like all right we need a strong hook in
the first two to three seconds
sure no please do yeah yeah all right
I'm gonna spin this globe and wherever
my finger lands I'm gonna find an artist
from that country to collaborate with me
on a song and see what happens
Zambia all right well let's find out
more about zandia I started researching
some up-and-coming artists and one guy
really stood out to me his name is Killa
he's a rapper from Lusaka which is the
capital of Zambia I felt like his style
and his voice would sound perfect on the
song I'm working on so I reached out to
him I sent him the beat and then a few
days later he sent me back
I know a lot of people praying for my
downfall but the only thing that I'll be
down for is being top five but like
Downs four I'm down to earth like the
ground floor but I've been flying so
long I tend to ask people what's the
ground for man I'm only headed up see my
flow volcanic justify I erupt heard the
fans getting rowdy cause they haven't
had enough you know I'm running the city
you're just running out of luck yeah I
said that with my chest so that whole
thing five seconds there like the speed
that you hit him with that initial hook
like you're already started you're like
mid word you're like all right I'm gonna
spin this globe now you're doing
something interesting visually and then
you set up the premise the stakes of
like wherever my finger lands I'm gonna
find an artist and do a song with them
which okay I've never heard of that
before so where does this idea come from
and like how much time times you put
into that first getting that first five
seconds to be good I was literally at
the gym with Connor's mom and I thought
of it and I texted him I said I'm start
I'm stopping at Target we're grabbing a
globe here's the idea and his mom parked
the car I ran and got it it was like 19
bucks and to be honest at the time we
didn't realize it would blow up and we
posted on a Sunday and it got three
million views the same day and I'm like
oh okay this is a series we have to
do this again and instantly I went on my
phone I'm like what country's next and I
searched hashtag Dutch rap because I
really wanted a Dutch artist I think
that language is so beautiful and I
found this guy named Benz then we did
episode two two weeks later and boom
that's spinning in it that's the song
that now has over 100 million streams on
Spotify in less than nine months that's
so insane it is insane yeah so that
first one that that you were just
playing um it really was just like okay
how do we make content around the song
what's the contentable moment and what's
something visual what's something visual
we can do right so for spinning like the
the other one you played with the carrot
flute it was that idea of like all right
this fluid is such a strong element of
the song I remember watching a video
back in the day where someone made it no
no no no Christian our brother-in-law
was making a carrot food at Christmas
and we're like you're an idiot what are
you doing and it actually ended up
working and I'm like what if we bring
that into the video right and then
that's what made the song now people
like call him like the carrot flute guy
and I'm like what so for this one the
contensible moment for us was like all
right we have this artist myself from
Canada we have this other artist from
Zambia a country that most people don't
even know where it is on the map so you
you actually you actually knew the
artist you had the artist idea first
you're like how do we tell the story of
that almost in reverse engineer the
story correct for this one we had the
song first for every other one we were
like we had no idea this was going to
blow up all our content that it
performed well at this point was Skits
and every time we posted a non-skit it
never did as well so we really were just
like let's see what happens I was very
much inspired by like content creators
like um Mr Beast yeah as you can tell
from like the whole editing style and I
edit them my tick tocks and so like the
one word at a time I love how in videos
it starts the first frame you hear all
right guys today we're gonna blah blah
blah he just gets into it right away and
so I was inspired by that hence uh this
intro yeah the first one we had the
relationship with the Zambian artist
first but after the first episode it was
very organic and we found the artists
like literally two days before the song
was recorded and why do you think this
video popped off like that I think the
hook is really strong I'm gonna spin
this globe wherever my finger lands it's
like all right where what's about to
happen is he gonna go there
um immediately you're interested where
he's gonna land right and it's it's
visual you see a spinning globe now now
you're gonna stick around and see all
right let's see where it lands I land on
a country like Zambia something most
people haven't heard of and I say I'm
going to collaborate with an artist now
there's another hook of oh what's this
guy going to look like what's he gonna
sound like what's the song gonna sound
like and then they stick around today
it's even going to be good right totally
and how many times did you have to spin
that Globe to land on sale oh gosh I
couldn't even tell you way too many
times yeah that's another good Tick Tock
like uh yeah every every couple seconds
like every four to five seconds there's
just something new there's like a new
like if you're thinking of leaving
you're like okay wait maybe I'll stay oh
I'm thinking of leaving oh wait I want
to see him oh he's about to start I'll
stay like there's even with the carrot
flute video you'll notice every time
there's like a dull moment we have a of
the drill right and it's like oh I'm
staying like the weird brother pops in
and like surprises it's like every kind
of 45 seconds two or three seconds
almost like the attention is about to
lapse open up a new curiosity even we
even do that with the Music Creation so
if Conor's writing a verse and the flow
is the same for too long I'll be like
that's not contentable I need you to
switch your flow up faster so that there
can be a new moment where the Beat Drops
and the producer goes yeah like yeah
when once we started seeing how well the
content was doing for the music I
started approaching my my creative
process with writing the music thinking
about what the content would be and a
lot of times the content would come
first so I would think you know that
whole carrot flute video did so well and
then we started thinking what other
weird instruments could we use and then
we would think of a weird instrument
like a xylophone and then we made a
xylophone beat oh or one we wanted to do
one where the fire alarm goes off mid
recording session but he's like wait
stay that sounds sick and then they
bring out the b-pad and make a song we
wrap over a fire alarm yeah yeah so a
lot of times we would think of the
content first and then make the song was
there like a revenue number in mind that
you guys need to have in order to make
this a full time yeah my my dream was
like I want to make ten thousand dollars
a month from this I'm like if we can
make ten thousand dollars a month I'll
be like the happiest person in the world
and I don't know if I don't know if you
guys know how it works but it's roughly
there's a lot of variables but on
average a million streams is around four
thousand dollars USD on Spotify on
Spotify and we're averaging like 60
million streams a month right now things
are just pretty crazy and I don't think
most people know that there's that
potential because
in music you hear there's no money in
streaming but I'm like that's because
labels own 80 of your songs but if you
own your songs there's a ton of
money in streaming and I kind of want to
just bring awareness to that yeah well
what was like the all right so you guys
were just doing your thing and then
there was that that pop moment what was
the first month of sales on the pop like
when it when it when the when the first
video really worked out there's a three
month delay in accounting so whatever
you get from like January February March
you get it in April and I remember that
pop moment got us our first six figure
month yeah and we lost our minds what
were you making per month before that
like uh was it like kind of under 10
that under a thousand dollars to over a
hundred thousand yeah yeah no that Globe
series really like if I showed you the
chart of my Spotify for artists you see
my daily streams were here and then it
just explodes like way up what's really
cool is that a lot of people have a big
moment and then they slow down they get
comfortable but the second we had that
big moment I'm like we're pulling
all-nighters we're going harder than
we've ever gone so you can see the chart
it goes up and it stays up which is like
the beauty of it because we didn't stop
like I literally remember our baby was
sleeping he was four months old during
the globe series and we would take turns
pulling all-nighters Connor would be
editing the videos go in give them a
bottle keep editing it was crazy we were
on crack I don't think we would I don't
know how we did it but last night when I
was watching all the videos I thought
Connor is a genius and then now I
realize that
Brianna's a genius actually and um and
actually Connor you could just a little
bit of drink of water I just have a
thousand questions for this is so uh
amazing so you really did Christianity
I'm curious just for relationship point
of view uh when did uh how did y'all
meet when did you meet and like at the
time was it like I'm gonna be a rapper
and you're like you got it honey go for
it no we were 10 and 11 years old we
lived in the same apartment complex
um yeah when I was telling you earlier
when I did that movie Cinderella Man
that so the the first time I went to LA
for that Premiere uh after that I
started staying in La for a few months
every year for auditions and stuff like
that and we would stay at this this
apartment complex called the oakwoods
apartment
um which was kind of Infamous for having
like a lot of child actors stay there
and Brianna's little sister Chloe used
to act and so her family and my family
lived at that apartment complex at the
same time and I was 10 and she was 11
and that's that's when we first met yeah
and we stayed friends we swapped aim
addresses and
and then like it's just a cool story
because
you were supporting him I imagine I I
don't know what the life of an actor is
like but you're yeah you you were you
were supporting him and then
you know now you guys are a team I mean
that's just like it's like flip-flopped
because his acting was much more
lucrative than you think like when we
first got married he was on a series
called X company he did three seasons of
that and he was a lead on that and it
does pay quite well I don't know if I'm
like contractually even allowed to say
so I won't but at the time he was more
supporting me and then I uh was working
and I did I was a nanny at the time so I
wasn't like bringing in like huge
amounts of money and then I did the pet
company stuff and during that time he
wasn't working so then I was supporting
him yeah and now we've come to this like
even ground we're working together and
supporting each other and our family my
sister my brother-in-law my little
brother everyone quit their jobs and
they're all working on our team so it
really just is a family operation we go
to coffee shops every day they help us
edit they help us like manage the house
they're watching our baby right now so
we could do this my brother-in-law
Christian mixes and Masters all the
music he produces a lot of it that whole
carrot flute he played that on the
recorder
um so yeah we we keep it all in the
family we all SWAP who supports who and
I knew I'm like one day there's going to
be a point where we can all just support
each other with this like big thing but
I don't know what's going to be I wasn't
expecting it to be Connor rapping music
we had a guy on the Pod a long time ago
you might know him his name's Mike Brown
and it's one of the earlier episodes and
I forgot what he was doing exactly it
was some like mineral oil exploration
thing so he would go he would basically
knock on people's houses and be like hey
did you know there's like some minerals
under the ground that you live in
um and if you sign this paper that says
like cool
um you have the rights to like get that
get those minerals out dig those
minerals out or whatever mine them
um you can get paid this amount of money
today up front you can get this amount
of money today and if you got like if
there's a hundred houses he needed all
100 to sign and if he got that then he
could sell that that bundle of of
letters saying yep you have the rights
to a company that actually does the
mining he was making millions of dollars
doing this in Texas and um he was like
yeah I was doing this and I was like
that doesn't sound like it takes a lot
of people he's like no it's just me and
then my he's like I brought on my two
brothers and I was like oh what's that
like working with family because like
you know you hear different things this
is before I started a business with my
wife I was like you know what's that
like
and he's like
he just looked at me like I was stupid
and he was like what do you mean so it's
the best and I go oh I mean like I guess
you guys get along or works out he's
like no of course you know it's not all
perfect but he's like my theory of life
is you find the people that you love and
then you do life with them and that just
like has been ringing in my ears for
like three years now it's like find
people you love and then do life with
them to find excuses to do things with
them whether it's work vacation or
learning something together or joining
us you know learning a sport together
whatever it is
um would you say that's accurate for for
you guys or do you guys have anything
that maybe will ring in my ears for
another three years about this I'd say
I'd say it's accurate but there
definitely are like we have to plan date
nights or else we will never spend time
together as a married couple we turn
into just business partners for a while
and that's it or like for example we'll
get in an argument as married couples do
but then we have a podcast interview the
next morning or a video to shoot so we
have to put aside our pride of like
who's right or wrong to make the work
come first for my siblings if they get
in a fight I just have this talk with
them last week I'm like you guys are
messing up my ecosystem we have like a
family ecosystem right now if you fight
with you then now Conor can't mix his
music with him and then if he's so
everyone just freaking get along so
sometimes I have to like
yeah person that's like stop fighting
because business
yeah literally and then I'm like there's
a point where we're gonna sell
everything make a ton of money and then
we can all live on a farm and fight all
we want but for now freaking get along
I can find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
and you just did a so like the way that
this is transferring to like actual
wealth and money and everything is the
Spotify you get paid off that I don't
know if you can get paid off Tick Tock
or not but you just did a tour as well
so you you and Hoodie Allen did like a I
think what did you say two or three
weeks it was three weeks in Europe yeah
I was opening for him actually wrote
down our revenue streams just because I
didn't want to forget
I'd say the time go for it yeah yeah
it's like Sam's gonna ask about revenue
streams I'd better be prepped we have
streaming is the number one by far we
have YouTube Money YouTube actually pays
quite well in in regards to social media
platforms YouTube is like the platform
yeah I'll just say this really quick
because this is kind of cool so I found
out that in them so I I was pretty late
to YouTube shorts I watched a Mr Beast
podcast where he was talking about you
know YouTube shorts being the future I
was like all right let me just try this
and what I did was I took all my popular
tick tocks and because I edit them I
have them all my computer saved and I
just repurposed them on shorts and you
know without the tick tock Watermark or
anything I took the original you know
and just reposted and YouTube emailed us
and they're like you were the most
subscribed to artist in November yeah
and all artists in the month of November
yeah they set up did you just reply damn
right send I said is there like a plaque
for that or something yeah so I got 800
000 subscribers in one month just just
from posting every day for a full month
all my popular videos including stuff I
heard something funny by the way I don't
know if this is true or not might be a
conspiracy theory but somebody was
saying like uh obviously this part was I
think showed to be true which is if you
just re-upload your tick tocks with the
watermark uh like Instagram and YouTube
I think were de-prioritizing I don't
like it but yeah so the original file is
good but actually they also scrape the
metadata the name the file name I don't
know if you guys are is this true or are
you guys aware of this
if if you have the same like MP4
file name underneath they also are
trying to match that to just see like oh
I don't know if that's true or not it
could it could be possible like
that Globe video we didn't change
anything which is kind of weird that
they both they both have exactly 72
million views on both platforms and I I
posted them months apart because like I
said I was late to shorts
um so now because of YouTube that's an
extra five figure so yeah that's why I
brought that up was that which one grows
faster YouTube shorts or Tick Tock what
do you where do you which horse do you
see winning it's tough because the tick
tock algorithm changes so much but I
think right now we're more excited about
YouTube because YouTube lets you pin a
comment and a link to stream the song
but Tick Tock doesn't They removed the
pinned comment feature so it's harder to
convert Tick Tock views to streams right
now I had a call with Tick Tock and I
said bring that back so hopefully they
bring it back and even more
interestingly enough on Tick Tock there
so maybe my manager too right this is
amazing YouTube is much more Creator
friendly uh as far as you know when you
want to promote something like that that
video
um the first little video that I post on
YouTube I was able to make the pin
comment the streaming link for the song
yeah and that comment has like 40
thousand upvotes and so it definitely
allow people to get to the streaming way
easier than tick tock tick tock at this
point too even if you try to write the
word Lincoln bio or even Spotify they'll
hide the comment and we've tested this
I've written that I've posted that
comment under my own video logged into a
different account to go there and the
comment's gone and so they don't want to
encourage anybody off the app obviously
so business but finish this out yeah so
it's Spotify
it's YouTube then brand deals
so uh recently like the last couple you
can negotiate like six figures High six
figures depending on the ask I'm sure we
could get even higher but like in our
current state current followers it's
like six figure deals sinks which is
like getting your songs and commercials
or TV video games video games all that
stuff
um publishing
um can you explain publishing real quick
in like two sentences oh it's hard to
explain two sentences but yeah pretty
much like a song has two parts to it
there's like the master which is
um
um also called the sound recording which
is what the uh streams are yeah what the
streaming royalties are and then there's
the publishing side which is like the
writers the songwriters um and so the
publishing
um you get paid for like performance
rights so if it gets played on the radio
if someone wants to cover your song and
use your lyrics so so it's sort of like
a different part of the pie that's so
Pub and then merch and then live shows
so those are like our one two three four
five six like seven streams of Revenue
and people don't know this like are you
negotiating all this are you I mean
that's very impressive if you're the one
also doing the the publishing stuff and
commercials and things like that I mean
I was up until like three months ago for
the sinks I still am like if he needs to
get his stuff in a TV show or movie or a
game I'm still doing that but for brand
deals we brought on a brand agent team
because I just don't have the bandwidth
I was like losing my mind
because being a mom comes first and if
Jude is sick or having a tough day and
things are due I'm like I need someone
else to take this so we do have a brand
agent negotiating the brand deals um but
everything else is us and so you
um you have these uh revenue streams
most of the time I've heard that touring
is like number one for a lot of artists
you put it at the bottom we were just
talking about this on a walk last night
I'm like how are we going to talk about
touring because it's just not I don't
like to speak confidently on anything
we've never done ourselves yeah
um of course if you're at like Drake
Taylor Swift level blah blah you're
bringing in hundreds and millions of
dollars but just for context we opened
on the European tour and I had a chart
of the money I'm pretty sure we just
broke even on that one just because you
have to like rent a bus you have to pay
a tour manager you have to pay for
everyone to travel your DJ merch
think about that because it's obviously
a lot of effort you got a little baby at
home yeah um you could you probably
reduce your output on Tick Tock because
you're touring because it takes up so
much time you break it even but there's
the fan love and you're like okay this
means something and like that matters
um and you know I think most artists
just give you the politically correctly
oh I do everything for my fans and blah
blah blah but like there's a reality
there's trade-offs to everything me and
Sam experience this in a super small
level with the podcast where we did a
couple live shows they're fun but
they're a lot of work you don't make any
money off of it and it's kind of like
well that was just one episode like we
could have just done so much more in
that same amount of time so we kind of
and we both Sam doesn't like to travel
and I got little babies at home so I'm
not I'm not looking to travel either so
we kind of don't do it that much how do
you guys measure that uh think about
that trade-off of like the live Fan
Experience which is create super fans
but you lose all this other stuff we
found a really good medium for this we
met in the middle Conor's booking agent
I totally forgot to mention her earlier
which is ridiculous because she's iconic
uh Connor's booking agent her name is
Kara Lewis she also reps like Eminem and
a bunch of other really awesome artists
um and I've talked to other white
rappers she likes yeah oh my God yeah
young gravy she's got it she had Travis
Scott at one point she's got ice spice
right now she's she's literally the best
there's an article about her like and
it's called like the most terrifying
woman in music I'm like I want that to
be me like that's me next anyways so
we've come to a conclusion with her that
right now while Jude is in these early
stages of life and we're really just
trying to build build build we'll do
pop-up shows so for example we're doing
a pop-up show in Chicago in November and
then we're going to do a pop-up show in
Toronto his hometown a few days later
and then he'll accept like festivals
like
uh like a month ago he went to Calgary
for a rodeo and he did a festival where
they offer you a certain amount of money
and you play for 45 minutes I'm like
easy right he's gone for two nights so
we're gonna do that and then just keep
doing pop-up shows to have fan love and
like connect with the audience because
it is really magical to hear people sing
his songs back to him in person yeah but
the tick tock experience is good too
though because the thing about digital
stuff is well I see it and even though I
see a hundred thousand likes or tens of
millions of views on it I'm like I I
don't know who else knows this and then
I saw the video of you in Europe and you
do really cool tick tocks of you like
before the show and then during the show
and I'm like holy this guy this is
a movement you know this is actually uh
it's it's sort of like when Casper and
all these companies that like when
digital companies start advertising and
buying Billboards in the uh Subways and
like that you're like oh it's
actually adds value to see it in real
life as opposed to just on my phone even
as a digital viewer you know what I mean
totally that's a great person yeah yeah
so for us right now shows aren't like
live shows like a festival is a money
thing it is a revenue stream because he
gets paid for like 45 minutes but the
concept of touring for us it wouldn't be
lucrative enough at this stage for us to
invest the time energy funds blah blah
blah into it but when he does do shows
it's purely fans I know a lot of artists
will like charge for VIP meet and greets
I'm like why am I charging a fan to say
hi to you they're the reason we have a
career no like he'll stand outside and
talk to absolutely everybody there for
free he'll go to the merch table sign
merch the venues will try and even like
fee us for that they're like if he's at
the merch table there's gonna be a fee
like that's so silly but anyways when we
do do live shows it's going to be
completely just for the fans and not a
revenue stream how big of a venue can
you sell out right now you think we've
honestly never tested that because we've
never done a headlining solo show but
I'll get back to you in a few weeks when
we guess
you can guess
our our hope is somewhere between 900
and a thousand those are like dude well
hey you know it's like the thing so I
mean technically you like who knows you
could sell out
a 5000 venue like you never know but in
the touring world you have to like build
a proof of purchase first so like you
can't just go from zero to booking a
massive venue you have to start at this
venue and then your booking agent can
negotiate this venue and then this
because you have to like show them hey
he sold X many tickets here so now your
Venue should take him because you have
to negotiate with like the the promoters
and the club Owners and so it's hard to
say like touring is a tough topic
because one we're not versed in it
enough and two it's too complicated of a
business to be like I can go from here
to here you have to build it's not as
much like Tick Tock where we can go
viral overnight and your life changes
yeah that's true
sorry if that's a lame answer but it's
just so Mike Posner went to my high
school at my college when I was there
and we were all like this is a guy in
the other building that's trying to
become a rapper like what is he talking
about and
um that he did so that was kind of
amazing
um
and one of the things he did when he
kind of came back so he like had his
high like the traditional way and then
he kind of hit a low or like he wasn't
making hits anymore like his first album
was like whatever big and then like he
kind of dipped a little bit and then he
like reinvented himself and he's like
I'm gonna walk across America so he
started doing things that I thought were
interesting because he added new layers
to him New Dimensions new content kind
of like ideas he wasn't doing it for
that reason but it worked well also and
that he would do these pop-up shows just
in a park or he would just be like I'm
just gonna start playing in this park
and see what happens but like like it
kind of didn't matter what happened live
like some people got a magical
experience that came or were there most
people weren't there but he's like what
does it matter if like
okay let's say there's 50 people here
that are having like a 100 out of 10
experience because like something over
the top cool just happened
and okay I don't have 900 other people
here but this video looks so interesting
and it makes me more interesting than
the how a traditional artist does it so
the content would always pop off and his
brand would be kind of like the people's
champion in a way that he would just do
these free shows in the park rather than
um rather than like how you know an
artist would just do things so I think
you know there's something to flipping
touring on its head and be like I am
going to do these fan things on my own
terms but I'm actually going to do them
optimized for content and not filling
venues because content's my game anyways
and if I just keep building that
mountain right that's what Mr Beast does
he's like if I just like building this
mountain
like everything in this business it's
like what's your goal like if your goal
is to be a mega Superstar and perform in
arenas then yeah sign with a label and
do those things and dedicate your life
to building your touring resume so you
can get there but that's just not our
goal at least right now so we're just
focusing on making as much music as
possible because I forgot who said I
think it was this artist named Mike Stud
he compared songs to real estate he's
like if you can buy a piece of real
estate every two weeks why wouldn't you
some of them will remain Shacks on the
beach but some of them will be mansions
in Laguna so that's our mindset right
now I'm like we're investing in as much
real estate what is your goal what's
like your what's like do you guys have
like a like do you want to do this for
30 years are you trying to you just get
super rich I mean what's like what do
you write on the Whiteboard or in the
fridge business business like he loves
the art and we love to make good music
but ultimately the goal would be to
scale this like we would scale a
business and then uh potentially sell
the catalog someday because it can be
evaluated similar to a what number what
number excites you 50 million
at what age
three or four years from now yeah okay
I'll be your advisor no charge just add
a zero to that number
okay because that you're like you guys
uh 50 is you guys you're already
fingertips away Sean how's 100 million
no no that is 500 is the number what did
what did Bruce Springsteen get dude I
think Bruce Springsteen got 300. you
know I want to say something here that's
a little bit so I've definitely uh
this is probably the most I've ever like
you know complimented any guest on this
podcast before usually even if I like
them I you know I'm hard to get a little
bit uh Sam's usually just like Sam's
usually fangirls pretty easily he's like
he's like so you're hot and I just love
people that are hot and like you know
you're fit so like you know you're
awesome and uh you know I usually keep
it you know a little close to the best
but but you guys are you're the you're
the creative version of hot and I think
that's amazing and you're hot thank you
yeah yeah we'll take the physical as
well the thing that I would say that's
kind of an insult is when I watched you
on YouTube I didn't have the same fun as
I did on Tick Tock so like I watched the
full songs and I was like these are good
songs
but I didn't like you know I wasn't like
hooked and I wasn't
um like
I wasn't as like I felt like the things
you guys are doing on Tick Tock I've
kind of never really seen before it felt
so original and uh it almost felt like a
different thing than like music which is
like a thing I understand and there's a
bunch of like pre-established
music options that I can go to I'm
curious do you guys feel this uh hey do
you feel the same way and B like is
there any part of your ego that's like
no I like I want to be a traditional
take me serious rapper versus like no
this kind of like these Tick Tock quick
hooks almost like half songs that's my
thing and I'm actually creating a new
Lane over here how do you think about it
the goals are different on those
platforms on Tick Tock our goal is to
reach new listeners and YouTube is more
to nurture the listeners we already have
and to nurture the platform because it
does pay well so more views on YouTube
is more money in our pocket from the
AdSense and stuff like that but yeah
with YouTube we're not approaching those
long form videos with the goal of
reaching new people if that makes sense
it's kind of hard to explain and then
also sometimes if the videos are a bit
more polished like for example he did a
song with baby no money and that was a
very polished music video but like
that's like baby's team right they were
like all right if we're gonna do a song
with Connor Connor's got to jump into
our world and do a music video I'm like
great then you gotta jump into our world
and do a skit so yeah well the thing
about your skits is like first of all
like I I see a tick tock video and then
I listen to you guys when I work out
like I I associate it it goes video
first then I listen to a while I'm
exercising that's her goal but I um when
I see the video like you do this you
have this amazing thing where you
basically you're clearly an actor you
have three characters you have the
producer then you have you the rapper
and then you've got your nerdy brother
or cousin or whoever you're supposed to
be the guy yeah like the guy who wears
the turtleneck and I get to know the
characters and you do such a good job I
was telling Sean I was like I forget you
forget that it's it's Connor you do even
obviously it's you don't dress up or
anything just the same person you do
such a good job that I'm getting to know
the characters it's very much like yeah
the Doctor Doolittle or whoever it was
you know Tyler Perry where they played
the it's the same actor doing multiple
characters but you're not even dressed
up I get to know the characters and I
like see the the weird brother come in
and I'm like oh he's about to do
something funny
um and I get to know the the personality
of the producer uh version of you it's
so good you do such a good job of like
adding characters that when I listen to
the songs I am like I'm remembering that
video and that's what makes me like it
for us if it was just the songs they are
good but I the the the skits add so much
meaning to it I'm like oh this is the
carrot one you know what I mean it's so
cool um and the funny thing is so like
like music like if you listen to an
album they they've always done these
like skit type things and I'm like back
when I used to have CDs like Kanye's you
know uh College Dropout album there
would be these little skits but they
weren't that good and like they they
weren't that funny they were kind of
long and like
um so that concept's been around how did
you guys come up with this idea to have
these character how did you come up with
the idea for the characters uh like what
what was the inspo behind that the
characters was really just like we don't
have anyone else like we're really like
we don't really hang out with many
people uh we couldn't think of anyone
who could play these characters as well
so I'm like kind of just freaking put on
glasses and just be yeah it was just it
really was just the most efficient way
to do it and I I had control over the
whole process because I was I film it
all myself I set up my iPhone filmed
them late at night when the bait it's
like well you can't coordinate that with
other people like hey can you can you
come over at 11 PM for a tick tock like
No One's Gonna Do That
like you have this other video uh I
forget I don't even know who the rappers
are like eventually I figure out oh this
that's pretty Allen but in the video I'm
just like oh it's a the skit is like
it's a late night thing the janitor has
to fill in yeah and I just know the
actor as the janitor not even the rapper
then you see him rapping and I'm like
happy it's really good this is like
really creative stuff we would love to
our Dream would be to like um almost
make a not a parody
but of like the office but call it the
studio where we can kind of extend these
characters a bit more and like go a bit
deeper into them and maybe bring on a
few like if we have a episode of the
studio where Conor's all these
characters and then the guest is like
Idris Elba comes in and he acts on it
and then we get Courtney Cox to come in
on the next episode and we use these
connections Conor has from acting to now
Elevate his Tick Tock skits yeah that'd
be fun and then I have another dream of
like pitching Spin The Globe to Netflix
I'm like how cool would that be if it's
a 45 minute episode of Conor spinning
the globe lands on a country then he
actually flies there and we meet the
artist and we see their culture and we
see the music scene there like for
example Zambia
we have to go there because it would
blow your mind he couldn't send us his
video because he only had 12 hours of
electricity allotted like per day and he
said until we get a heavy rain the
government will not increase our
electricity so I can't send you my video
clips so we were waiting to post this
episode because
you don't have electricity in Zambia to
send these videos so I'm like I want to
go there and see this and like bring
awareness to it and I think that'd be so
cool because you have food shows on
Netflix you have like Zac Efron changing
the world everybody feeds Phil everybody
or somebody if you fail yeah I'm like
Connor should go there and do that but
for music I think that'd be so sick well
you there's a few there's a few like
paths here I think and there's a few
examples one example which I'm not
relating it as an insult but Weird Al
Yankovic like I bet you I don't know
this for sure
but I would bet you that Weird Al
probably out earned most every artist
from the 90s I bet you he crushed it in
terms of obviously it was in the CD era
where it was 22 for a CD that costs 50
cents to make but I bet you Weird Al
crushed it and then the other guy and
again I'm not saying it's just because
he's another white rapper but Little
Dicky you know he's got that awesome
show Dave he's done a really good job of
parlaying this thing into more than just
music and rapping but I wish Dave did
though which I was so disappointed in
the songs on the track were so good and
he's just now releasing them I'm like
those songs should have been out because
so not only are you making money from
your show but you're also making money
because your Spotify is about to go up
so that's another thing if we were to
spin the globe all the songs would be
out you watch the episode and then you
can instantly stream it yeah yeah that's
another part of our rollout is is we we
don't promote the song Until It's out
some people promote the song months in
advance they do pre-save campaign stuff
like that what were you gonna say about
that Sam well what I was going to say
was you we are Al and Dave are like uh I
actually think Weird Al is even more
talented than Dave but they're both like
this like cutesy type of thing I
actually don't view you that way I view
you as like significantly more serious
like you like you're not like I I'm
laughing with you never at you whereas
with Dave it's usually at you know what
I mean but he's still done a really good
job of taking these over-the-top music
videos and turning them into a thing but
uh I actually think that you have more
potential than him for sure because uh
with you you're relatable but at the
same time aspirational and like you're
still serious but at the same time funny
I don't know I just it's such a nice
compliment but it's so hard to respond
to because that this is that's just hard
to respond to I don't know what else to
word it but we like Dave and he's like
little dickies so good and I just think
I just admire you guys I just I think
that you Bri like you're you're gonna
you're just you you both have the it
factor and it's so evident and I think
the reason Sean said add a zero to it
was because
we don't know anything about music but
we've hung out with a whole bunch of
rich people a lot of billionaires and
and like you see like some patterns
and certain things and it's like oh well
this is yeah like we don't know how big
this is gonna be it's already big but
it's going to be significantly larger
than the way it is now if you have a
little bit longer of a Time Horizon and
just keep like doing pretty good how
long does it take you to create to
create a video or a video with a song so
what is the creative timeline for for
you know one of these that you make it
could be like I'm looking for songs made
or the song isn't made yet yeah I guess
either way or like for example this uh
the top video right now on your Tick
Tock is this collab the Branded collab
that you did
um yes with ruffles and KFC
um so you did that I assume you
basically had to you made something
specific for that it wasn't something
you already had made right correct um so
how long does a process like that take
you when you're going to create
something from scratch or is it just
some days it's one day some days it's
three months it's hard to say like do
you have a kind of a consistent formula
for creation first song some days I can
be three hours and some days it can be
weeks because he's stuck on something
sure but for videos I'll script
something in like 20 30 minutes and then
he'll film himself for a few hours and
then he'll edit for a few hours yeah on
average I'm probably filming for one or
two hours and then editing for one to
three hours and do they all have to be
full songs or do you just do like
I make you know three verses and that's
for this Tick Tock video but I'm not
turning it into a full song Do you ever
do that no from now we only will invest
time in a tick tock if it can convert to
streams or else that's just not
uh
lucrative for us I have like brain fart
but yeah uh for Ruffles they only
requested a 30 second demo so for that
one specifically he only had to write 30
seconds of a song boom done easy but
normally it's a full song needs to be
done or we won't post it because Tick
Tock doesn't pay you for views yeah but
it does indirectly because uh let's say
something goes viral now your fan base
grows the next video you put out with a
song uh you know it's gonna gonna pay
totally
um you know but if the song is out we
can show you the charts it'll get like
it's so much different if the song's out
yeah but I hear what you're saying but
like you know for I I admire people who
kind of like
uh there's a Temptation anytime you're
doing something new uh because new stuff
is so unproven there's a tendency and a
temptation to like take the energy and
the momentum from the new thing but
Shift Into The Proven game so for
example I did a comparison once of Joe
Rogan's podcast which is like an
interview talk show type type of thing
and I compared it to the top like uh The
Tonight Show
and I was like okay you know just I
forgot who's the host or which show I
did but like let's say Jimmy Fallon was
the the host of the show and it's
basically like if you just compare
across every key metric so it's like
audience size Joe Blows Joe's podcast
blows away Jimmy Fallon and actually has
for years and years and years like once
Joe got the Spotify deal then it was
like it got kind of like legitimized but
way before that Joe was making a ton of
money on a huge audience like five years
before that but people didn't think of
it like a business because they just
didn't have a headline of 100 million
dollars a year to Spotify that to like
latch onto so audience size Joe is
bigger
uh production it's Joe's podcast I think
it's Joe Jamie and like maybe one other
person it's like three or four people
total to pull off that show The Tonight
Show has like 50 people behind the
scenes just to like run one show
um like episodes per year he has like
more output with fewer people bigger
reach and the only thing that was
missing was like it wasn't didn't have
like a category that it fit into really
it was like it's a podcast okay podcast
like is that a business I don't really
know like it seems like there's a bunch
of those
uh but Joe stuck with it and like he had
a lot of offers to do other things but
he just stuck with it let it build build
build so that then by the time you know
it got really really big he could
promote whether it's his own product
like on it or some other you know
athletic greens or whatever some product
that pays him
and start making ludicrous money and Mr
Beast kind of does the same thing where
like he flirts with this idea of like I
could go create a Netflix show but the
reality is if you talk to him and you've
seen him do what he's been doing over
the last few years it's just like
build audience build audience through
this like what he's like why would I
leave YouTube I can reach more people
than the Super Bowl and you're like yeah
but it's different but
he's kind of not wrong like he he is
right it seemed like this frivolous
thing and then now people see Mr Beast
as like kind of a business entrepreneur
guy but like it's because of like it's
because he committed to this new Lane
like many years ago and I guess what I
would say for you guys is
it seems like you guys have a new Lane
of this kind of like
what I'm it's almost like Fast fashion
but for music which is like these tick
tocks that are hooky and and catchy and
skit based and like they can get
millions of views and build you a huge
fan base
um
and it I actually think if you just stay
with that and you don't try to be a
traditional musician you're going to end
up way bigger than all the traditional
musicians it's the problem is it's just
like a little bit unproven where that
goes exactly or like and it's very
tempting to like take offers from
legitimate Brands and and legitimate
like paths that you've heard of but the
good news is you're you're making
millions of dollars along the way you're
making millions now so at least it's at
least you ain't broke and we've talked
to every major label it's it's not like
I our friend Nick said that he's like
we're Independent by choice not by
default because you'll see in the
comments like why hasn't anyone signed
this kid yet someone signed Connor and
I'm like they've tried we will not
because that's not our goal our goal is
to like do this ourselves do things the
way we want to do it and honestly like
prove to other people that you can do it
um because I had no idea that this was
possible and I'd love for other people
that are making music to know it too how
old are you guys I'm 29 and Connor's 28.
wow and early on I remember you had this
cool video with Courtney Cox and then
you had another one with uh what's his
name
yeah those are cool have you had any
other uh like heroes or celebrities
reach out that you that floored you
um there's one guy I really look up to
his name is Russ he he's uh yeah he's a
huge independent artist he really kind
of wrote The Blueprint that I followed
as well I want to talk to into someone
about independent touring it would be
Rusk because I know Russ does it and he
sells out massive like if you want to
talk about the financial part the
business part of touring he'd be the one
to talk to his his song Civil War gets
me pumped up great son yeah he's he's
amazing but yeah Russ rust reached out
yeah so he like dm'd and showed love
which was just really cool because he's
sort of been my North Star as far as
just like how to do this independent he
wrote like
unsolicited advice stay independent
you'll be making M's like clockwork and
I'm like that's all I needed to hear I
think things are us
that was that was really cool one for me
he only talks in raps too that's amazing
uh because his DMS it's so hard because
that the the DMS are so like
um simu reached out
yeah yeah yeah he he's amazing um I yeah
I can't I'm like you know when people
ask you a question on the spot and
you're like name a song and you're like
uh I don't know any songs yeah there'll
be random things where like I'll notice
on Tick Tock like oh Logan Paul liked
the video or T-Pain liked the video like
you know there'll be little things like
that that's cool but as far as like
directly talking to someone the the big
one that comes to mind is is Russ just
because he's someone who I'm trying to
emulate as far as the business goes I
know you're in Vegas is it translating
into off the screen stuff you know are
you walking around uh downtown Vegas and
people are coming up to you has has that
been happening that's been the weirdest
part because like I said we stay in our
bubble and we hadn't been leaving the
house much especially during kelvid and
then we went on a trip to Salt Lake City
because we love Utah it's so random but
we went there and it was a ton and
especially at the airport like the TSA
agents are always like oh my God wait
they'll like look at his ID and then be
like the music guy like we love your
stuff and I'm like that's crazy but the
best is when little kids come up and
they have their little are you a
YouTuber
and they're so cute and it's like hey
yeah what's up and we had like a
five-year-old Super Fan come to Calgary
to meet him at the rodeo and Connor took
him to Tim Hortons for donuts
um but yeah that that's that's really
cool because you get to see it translate
in real life and especially when it's
kids and you're like oh that could have
been like a core memory for that kid
that's really cool yeah now that you are
winning in one lane what I found is that
when people are are let's say winning
and let's say that right now you're
winning in like this content music game
um you'll often see it's like kind of
like Neo in The Matrix you sort of see
the game a little differently you sort
of see opportunities that you know like
oh I feel like other people could be
doing this in this other lane or
we could do this but you know you know
we think that would work but you know we
just have our hands full so we're not
going to do it but like do you have you
seen any what I call adjacent
opportunities for either content
creators or on the business side like
have you you've come from a business
brain right so like do you see other
opportunities
this guy Kevin he has this account on
Instagram called icon brick and he makes
Lego animations and I've seen a couple
big rappers and labels hire him to make
Lego animations for their songs long
story short he's an incredible
songwriter and I was telling him the
other day dude put out your own music
and use this platform You're Building to
promote your own music like yeah every
like 10 to 12 videos you're doing like
other rappers but then slide in one of
your own videos in there with your song
wow this is sick I'm watching one of
these videos now oh they're incredible
we're actually really we're releasing a
song with him in a couple he only has
127 000 followers you're buying early on
this guy this yeah dude he's in he's
insane I'm like that's a double Revenue
stream you'll be making money from label
is paying you to make Lego animations of
their songs meanwhile you'll be
pocketing
Spotify revenue for your own songs so
that's like a perfect example
um
that just won't happen that one happened
recently so I can think of it I can't
think of any others that are super
recent you know what's crazy is with
Tick Tock like
it's just crazy how sound bites are
becoming songs so you know like there's
that one on Tick Tock where it's that
lady going uh I want to thank my man
thank you for my man I saw that the
other day it was just a so she said that
like yeah she she just said that at a uh
at a award show and that turned into a
clip and then yeah it was just it was
her saying it and I don't know if she
did it or someone else turned it into a
thing and then there's this other one
where there's this guy he's got a 30
second video
um uh Rick talks about his uh his boo
thing uh but it it it's literally a 30
second clip of him rapping and I'm
Googling for this guy and he's got it
has a million likes on Instagram on
reels and I'm Googling I'm like I want
to see the whole song it's not even a
song There Is No whole song it is just
like his 30 second clip and it's it's
pretty amazing how uh like things are
happening with music where like it's
just like a clip of a thing it's not
even real I guess the best example of
that is the corn kit remember that kid
that I was like I love corn and it
became this Viral Song on Tick Tock for
like six months yeah it's amazing but
that's actually something we've clocked
and we've wanted to be uh careful of
because sometimes people have their song
go viral the sound but people don't
connect that sound to the artist yeah so
there were a couple like viral sounds if
you asked me who the artist was I'd have
no idea so I was like we need to be very
cognizant of that and like make sure
that we attach you to the songs as much
as possible which is why we're so like
long form skit focused rather than like
let's make a sound pop off
because it's great it could be like a
moment and a spike for a song but long
term the goal is to attach Connor to his
music more do you uh on your way up like
kind of like when you were moving boxes
at the alpha Paul warehouse and you're
you know in between acting gigs you
maybe trying to make it in the music
game and it's it's not obvious you're
like now you're winning and winning
feels great but
you probably spent many years losing
this is how I felt in the world of
Entrepreneurship I yeah from the ages of
21 to 29 I was only doing startups that
failed that's like
I don't know eight years straight of
just getting my ass kicked did you like
dread going to family events because we
dreaded it because it's just like the
hey how are things going how's the
little music thing yeah
no people would be like what's what's
the new one because they're so used to
me every year having a news story about
the new thing that's gonna be the big
thing I was like oh damn you're right
there is always a new one uh like I
wish just one of these was the one and
uh you know like that that was it so was
there any I guess like moments you
remember from the kind of the bottoms uh
that like you know either a decision you
made a talk you had with yourself some
advice you got that like sticks with you
or helped you during that time it was
just it was brie it was like you know I
I
I don't have a bunch of friends which
that sounds strange I'm I'm a very
social person and I get along with
everybody but my my core circle is very
small and I spend 90 of my time with
Bree whether that's us working together
or we go on walks every night and we
just talk about stuff and yeah there was
definitely a period especially when kova
hit and Productions completely halted so
I had already a year before that been
struggling to get acting work and then
now there weren't even auditions and I
was definitely at a low point and was
like what do I do and
um Bree was somebody who very early on I
had shown my music to
and this was prior to me show like I
used to just record at home by myself I
didn't show anybody it was just a hobby
I had because I loved hip-hop but I was
afraid to put it out into the world
because I was afraid of the Judgment I
would get I even had an alter ego called
like he's gonna kill me yeah yeah this
is called unidentified
unidentified I use like a fake name and
I would I would used to upload music on
YouTube anonymously just because I
wanted to see what people would think
about it and I was like that's stupid
right uh without like attaching me to it
and I was afraid what my friends would
think like oh of course like the actor
wants to be the rapper now and I was
like Frozen with
um judgment fear yeah exactly and and
Bree has always from the very start just
been such like
like my my number one supporter and has
given me the confidence and so when I
was in that low point and and music was
something that I was sort of playing
with she was like go all in on this
trust me try it like try Tick Tock like
what's the worst that's gonna happen
like nothing's going on anyways you know
and so she she was the one that
instilled that confidence to like go for
it and Ramon instilled that confidence
in me yeah I got hired at the pet
company as a social media assistant
and I met Ramon and then after that like
a month later he's like yeah no you're
my creative director 100 and anything I
ever wanted to start he's like I'd be
your first investor I'd be your first
investor and he believed in Conor so
much so I was taking that confidence
from Ramon who was my mentor and I
instilled it in him and Ramon told me he
was like I'm I'm whatever they're doing
I'm in and I'm like you're an idiot man
there's no there's no money in music
like what's there to invest in there's
nothing to invest in and he was like I
don't know but whatever there's
something here well I'm in you were
happy with the Lord he told me I was
homeschooled yeah up until high school I
went to uh public high school but prior
to that I was homeschooled yeah
and uh do you think that that like did
that help you in any way in terms of
what
I think so because when I was
homeschooled I used to like start
businesses I showed Ramon my business
card it was like Brianna Peterson it was
like violinist pianist vocalist dog
walker pet sitter babysitter hire me for
anything like I would I just had so much
time on my hands and also creatively I
would write children's stories I would
uh I have old videos from the apartment
complex I wanted to be a director so I
would go around filming all the kids
um like documenting their lives so being
homeschool gave me a lot of time on my
hands and I think it gave me like a
a need for creativity that most kids
didn't have because when you're in
school you're constantly entertained by
other kids but I just had my siblings
and I so I had to come up with ways to
entertain ourselves so we would remake
Spy Kids we would remake Disney movies
like we would film them ourselves edit
them like so all my family jokes so like
you've been doing this since you were
like four yeah you've always been making
content yeah so no one's asked The
Homeschool question before and I never
really thought of it till now that I
guess homeschooling really did correlate
because it like forced me to be
creative well the we we have like a
large male most of our listeners are men
the takeaway here is like get yourself a
strong woman to be your partner here I
mean like like this is this is like a
good this is a really great marriage it
seems like you got to get yourself a
strong woman to help make this all
happen um I'm a huge fan of Alex and
Layla hormozzi I think that they're a
super power couple you know what they
live in Vegas I think so I'm like gonna
try and run into them at Milk Bar one
night because they never skip dessert
whatever they say but they're a huge
inspo for the husband and wife business
relationship because there's really
nothing cooler like we get to work
together be parents together well I
think most people actually it's horrible
you guys make it work because you're you
you are both emotionally stable you have
similar values it seems you have similar
goals I think in most cases it's not
awesome I think working with family in
most cases is horrible well thank you no
I mean and we have our moments I don't
want to make it seem like it's always
just so so easy because like Bree had
kind of alluded to earlier it's really
easy to fall into this like we work
together with co-workers mentality when
every so often it's important to
remember that we are husband and wife
and we need to find that balance so
we're co-workers who kiss what's the big
what's the deal exactly yeah no big deal
we all do it
um do you uh we'll leave it this uh
Sam's about to be a dad you guys
recently uh had your first baby any uh
any advice by the way Sam have you heard
there's their song about about their son
there's a line in there he's like uh
it's like you got my eyes and I got your
back I was like oh that's sick yeah
that's a good life dude like I remember
watching that video and I was getting
emotional and and that's why I was like
I think you're better than Weird Al and
Dicky and all these people I mentioned
before is because like I see your stuff
and like they don't inspire me I like
them you inspire me I won't take any
more Little Dicky slander on this
podcast for the record uh I feel like
you know I let the first one slide the
second one you know he's cooler stuff
and I'm like oh like Lil Dicky is like
oh bro
out of this conversation
I love him but he like his character of
like this neurotic Jewish guy of like
always complaining like I I don't think
I want to be you or like I want to learn
from you in terms of the day-to-day life
it's more so your career is amazing and
I respect it and I like your music but
with Connor like when I saw that song
I'm like dude the values that you're
talking about the songs like I'm on
board with like I've been I'm inspired
to live a little bit better I love
hearing this from Sam and I'll I know we
have to wrap this up but I'll just to
jump on this point so many artists have
come to us and they're like Connor needs
more of a brand I'm like what do you
mean like he's not he's too normal like
he looks like every other guy on your
street blah blah and I'm like I'm pretty
sure that's why people really like him
because and you're way hotter than me
let's be real Sam what's up with you and
like hotness oh don't give me wait till
we you should show me your calves if you
guys
that's my one thing why'd you bring it
up show him your caps give me six months
I'll show them my cat they're like
they're just like he's got a private
Instagram account for just
but we're working on them we're working
on the Cavs but um yeah no just that's
really cool to hear because the realness
has always been something that I've had
a gut instinct to stick with so it's
cool to like hear that confirmation from
you this is the first time uh that um
Sean has fangirled out a little bit
absolutely it's me Sean it's so nice to
finally meet you and thank you thank you
for the support and for watching and
listening It generally means Sean asked
about baby advice yeah number one the
number one advice we have is like
and it's so cliche but just be so
present in those newborn days because
they flew by genuinely we look back at
old photos like a baby photo of Jude
will make me just cry instantly because
I'm like I wasn't
um
I wasn't like
oh no I was like I was so focused
on business like too much so I wasn't
like I would like hold him and wait for
him to nap just so I could go work more
but I wish at the time I was like
enjoying it more so that so that you
don't end up crying on a podcast one day
here we are no the anytime we get crying
we know our views are gonna go up yeah
so thank you and don't go on tour for
three and a half weeks because it was
fun but he missed uh he missed a lot I
think you're doing it right I think even
if maybe there were some moments where I
mean where you maybe think you weren't
present I have a feeling just watching
you on social media I have a feeling
you're doing things wonderfully and the
things you've said on the Pod about the
family business and everything I I think
you get I think you're crushing it in
life in business you're crushing it in
life you're probably crushing it even
harder yeah so thank you and I know what
you mean I look at those photos and I I
literally don't even remember I'm like I
don't remember her looking like this
right it's like obviously I remember
when I see it but I'm like oh man that
just feels like two different times and
kids are this funny thing where like for
me at least all day I'm like oh my God I
can't wait for you to go to sleep or
just like we get a moment of free time
and then as soon as we have free time
that's all me and my wife talk about is
it's like okay wait what do we want all
this free time for all we're gonna do is
talk about the kids anyways
um like the funny things that they did
today so it's like uh it's this cup that
like you know you can never really fill
up enough of but at the same time you're
like
um
I don't know it's like this weird
dueling thing I don't have like the
words or the wisdom to like articulate
it but I definitely feel it where it's
uh
you can never spend it's like an
infinite amount of time you could spend
but it's really not about the like you
know the duration of the time it's kind
of like did you kind of sink in and
appreciate it versus
um just like being there because I've
had many days where I spend hours and
hours and hours but I didn't really
like I didn't really
let it sink in uh you know I was kind of
passing the hours which is a little bit
different so yeah I know which one thing
once where it's like as soon as your kid
is annoying you put your phone down
because if you're present in the moment
that kid isn't annoying but if you're
trying to multitude you're trying to be
something the wines and the that's
that's when it becomes annoying so we've
done a really good job at like as soon
as the babysitter leaves at three
like we didn't we're just fully present
we're not but when he was a newborn we
weren't doing that as much so you're
gonna have more
um I don't know if I want to go through
the whole pregnancy thing again it was
really tough on me especially mentally
after I'm already a very anxious
uh
person
so I think having a newborn to care for
while recovering from giving birth at
home
um was pretty intense for me I don't
know if I would want to do it again but
we'll see I know we want to adopt I've
been looking at adoption websites I
literally lay in bed and like cry
looking at them because I just want to
adopt all of them but yeah I think we
got to see our son we got to see what
our DNA would look like combined he's so
funny he's he's amazing he's a little
Connor
um but moving forward I'm like I don't
know if I need that urge again I think I
would just like to adopt a little
Vietnamese baby from where my grandma's
from and honor her in that way you got
to make sure they can rap too yeah if
they can't rap we're not I'll be part of
the application I'm like they can't use
three syllable words by 12 months
they're out yeah if they can't play
three different characters in this skit
yeah they didn't pass it yeah no we
definitely want for a versatile child to
adopt yeah we need some head shots
well we appreciate you guys coming on
you're amazing oh my God we appreciate
you guys having us yeah this is an honor
thank you I feel inspired talking to you
I imagine I imagine Sean does too and uh
producer John Jonathan was texting me
and he goes I'm loving this they're so
damn likable
Jonathan that was my biggest fear not
being likable because I never really
come on camera or do stuff like this but
I knew Sam so I was like
okay I know Sam I want to do this but
normally I'm very fearful of criticism
I've always been pushing I think you
need to start like like your own
personal brand like you're you're so
knowledgeable in the music space that
like and and you're always behind the
scenes No no one knows who you are no
one knows how impactful you are and what
I do and I think I think you need to
start putting yourself out there that's
very nice for sure well totally I mean
if you look at um their marriage didn't
end well so that's not the great example
but the Rock's wife uh I forget her name
um what is her name Daniela they did
yeah but but they still work together
they have an interesting Dynamic oh yeah
they still work together and she's known
as being a pit bull like she is like
feared in the industry she's sharp and I
think she has more Talent underneath her
now but that's like an interesting
example other than the divorce thing of
of the business going well besides that
besides that uh we'll we'll Workshop our
uh our next analogy
well and people people hate on Kris
Jenner but uh in my opinion I love Kris
Jenner
she seems like she still has a pretty
healthy maybe I don't agree with all the
tactics but her kids and her have a
great relationship and it seems like
it's worked really well and everyone's
provided for I was interviewing a nanny
that nannied for them and I was like I
was like I'm probably not gonna hire her
but I did like five interviews just to
dig for information about what they're
like and she was like I think by the
third interview she picked up that I
only wanted to ask her questions about
what it was like there and um and I was
like yeah I'm super curious can you just
tell me some things and she was like not
really and I was like okay I respect you
for that that's that's fair uh we like
the Kardashians I once made Conor binge
watch a whole season with me I did I
didn't know how to feel at first and
then afterwards I'm like oh they're all
just Killers they're all killers yeah
like and you know you don't have to
agree with all the stuff they've done to
do famous but they seem like they have a
great room yeah they all stick together
the Loyalty of that family seems strong
um well thank you all for doing this
this is awesome thanks for having us
thank you so much everybody go Tick Tock
is that the first place you want people
to follow you sure yeah I mean just um
well honestly I think my Instagram is
safest I was gonna say streaming
services just like going to your
favorite streaming service type in my
name all of it type in my name Connor
price you'll see all my songs there yeah
uh but yeah Tick Tock Instagram oh you
know what can I plug one thing sure any
streamers or video Gamers uh creators
watching this all of Connor's music is
dmca safe so you can put it in your
videos without copyrights yeah I created
a playlist on Spotify uh under my
channel that's called like dmca safe
copyright free words all of my songs
that are copyright free because I have a
few songs that I did with other artists
and they have their labels get involved
so you can't use them but I have a list
of all of the songs that you could use
on your YouTube videos your intros for
your podcast whatever you want unlimited
use
um because I don't do YouTube ID I think
the long-term value of having creators
use your music is way more than like
trying to get a few dollars every month
because somebody use your song in a vlog
so yeah if you're a Creator and you are
looking for copyright free music I have
a bunch of that that I want people to
use and Bree you're on Twitter but you
don't have any follower or you're like
do I have a Twitter I don't even know oh
I found it I was gonna say you should
promote that because I bet a lot of
people are going to want to DM you oh I
signed up on threads I have threads okay
hit her up on threads but friends
doesn't have DMS you're gonna get a lot
of opportunities from this you you just
got the Brianna price handle honest I
got my Brianna price handle on Instagram
so yeah just search her up on Instagram
because yeah someday I want to and I
just got this Instagram handle I've been
dying to get it's called home studio
because I want to start a a newsletter
for Independent Artists and then
eventually I saw your newsletter it's
really horribly named by the way you
need to change that name no I stopped
that the independent one yes I stopped
it that's done the idea was good thank
you spelling was the worst I know I got
it that's done don't worry so I'm
switching I want to do home studio
because I want to build a newsletter for
Independent Artists and then also then
turn that into a potential we sell like
home studio kits where everyone's like
what mic do you use I'm like just buy
Connor's kit it comes with the mic
headphone interface smart everything you
can use to make money from home and I'll
record all my songs using that kit so it
sells itself amazing uh you guys are
awesome thanks for coming on I have a
feeling that the next time you guys come
on you'll be 10 times bigger because you
have the talent for it and I think
you've stumbled into something really
really amazing and I think if you just
keep going it's gonna it's gonna get
really big so thanks for coming on and
thank you that's the episode that's the
pod that's the Pod thank you thank you